[Music]
audiences that's of me it's like they
didn't know you were coming out that's
insane it's just like they didn't know
miraculous oh that was I I've been doing
this a long time a reaction like that is
very uncommon that was
[Applause]
so gorgeous as always
Thank You Conan handsome as always
that's all I wanted what did how brought
you came out with something Oh Conan
these are my very own well no tabloid
cover make it about my eggs well I'm
giving them to you
wow this is these are really these are
eggs that come from where we inherited
12 chickens on our property and so this
is you and your fiance fiance Justin
yeah so you know we can't we they pop
them out like crazy so we just keep
giving them away and so I figured I may
as well actually give I'd keep talking
about it so I actually thought I'd give
them to these are like super these are
fresh exits on your farm yeah you make
it true you may have a twin in there now
I'm getting sad
this is feel bad that's actually a
really good egg - you know these are
these look amazing thank you so much for
this how did you come to help show
wimzie on your desk actually no they
don't they little better we'll put
Eisenhower next time and then they look
masculine there we go eisenhower
[Music]
[Applause]
looks like he's motorboating okay you
guys did oh my god yes Andy makes a
great woman
exactly that is a crazy woman yeah yeah
that's fun
now this case you bought a place or you
got a place and they had chickens there
and you decided we're just gonna go with
this
well we yeah we weren't really really
excited that we were gonna they weren't
taking the chickens okay they just told
us how to feed them and what they
require and they left pasta they loved
your feelings they love to just talk to
your feeding your chickens pasta hey man
I just did what I was told
yeah maybe they're playing a joke on you
feed it pasta yeah we love lobster salad
yeah